GLENN GREENWALD FROM RIO.
THE AUDIO CUTOUT.
WANT TO BRING YOU A STORY YOU
MAY NOT BE AWARE OF AS WELL AND
THAT IS THAT SOME PROMINENT
REPUBLICANS IN WASHINGTON
ACTUALLY DON'T WANT TO END IN
NOVEMBER.
SEEMS REALLY IMPORTANT TO YOU,
MAYBE THE FUTURE OF THE COUNTRY
BUT SOME OF THEM ARE ACTIVELY
TRYING TO LOSE.
MITT ROMNEY IS ONE OF THEM.
HE IS WORKING AGAINST HIS FELLOW
UTAH REPUBLICAN SENATOR MIKE LEE
IN HIS REELECTION CAMPAIGN.
IT SEEMS LIKE A BIG STORY.
IT'S NOT GETTING A TON OF
COVERAGE.
SENATOR MIKE LEE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
YOUR RACE.
I HAVEN'T BEEN PAYING ATTENTION
BUT I STARTED READING ABOUT IT.
YOU'RE BEING PAINTED AS SOME
SORT OF DANGEROUS EXTREMIST.
YOU ARE NOT.
YOU HAVE YOUR FELLOW UTAH
REPUBLICAN SENATOR WORKING
AGAINST YOU.
HOW DID THIS HAPPEN?
>> HE'S EXPLAINED THAT HE'S GOT
TWO FRIENDS IN THIS RACE.
WHEN HE FIRST TOLD ME THAT, MY
REACTION WAS WHO IS THE OTHER
FRIEND?
WANTS TO REMAIN NEUTRAL.
I UNDERSTAND IT AND I RESPECTED.
HERE'S WHAT'S GOING ON, MY
OPPONENT IS A DEMOCRAT RUNNING
IN DISGUISE.
I UNDERSTAND THE COMMITMENT MADE
BY MY COLLEAGUE AND I WORK WITH
HIM, I LIKE HIM.
HERE'S THE DEAL.
I DON'T THINK MITT ROMNEY WANTS
CHUCK SCHUMER TO CONTINUE TO BE
THE SENATE MAJORITY LEADER.
IF I AM RIGHT ON THAT, HE NEEDS
TO GET ON BOARD BECAUSE THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT HE'LL BE PRODUCING.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT IT WILL LEAD
TO.
IF UTAH GETS TRICKED INTO
ELECTING EVAN ON, A CLOSETED
DEMOCRAT INTO THE UNITED STATES
SENATE, AS SOON AS MITT ROMNEY
IS READY, I WILL EAGERLY ACCEPT
HIS ENDORSEMENT.
GO TO LeaveForSenate.com AND
MAKE DONATIONS TO MY CAMPAIGN.
BASED ON THIS IDEA THAT HE IS
GOING TO DEFEAT ME AND HELP
PERPETUATE THE DEMOCRATIC
MAJORITY.
>> Tucker: MAYBE YOU DON'T
WANT TO SAY THIS OR YOU'RE NOT
AWARE OF IT.
I BELIEVE IT'S TRUE THAT MEMBERS
OF MITT ROMNEY'S IMMEDIATE
FAMILY, HIS NUCLEAR FAMILY ARE
ACTIVELY HELPING McMULLEN
AGAINST YOU.
IS IT POSSIBLE TO CALL
MITT ROMNEY WHO I KNOW YOU'VE
KNOWN PROBABLY YOUR WHOLE LIFE
AND SAY PLEASE, LIKE, THERE'S A
LOT AT STAKE HERE.
>> I HAVE ASKED HIM.
I AM ASKING HIM HERE AGAIN
TONIGHT RIGHT NOW.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO PROTECT THE
REPUBLICAN MAJORITY, GIVE US ANY
CHANCE OF SEIZING THE REPUBLICAN
MAJORITY ONCE AGAIN, GETTING IT
AWAY FROM THE DEMOCRATS WHO ARE
FACILITATING THIS MASSIVE
SPENDING SPREE, MASSIVE
INFLATIONARY BINGE, PLEASE GET
ON BOARD, HELP ME WIN
REELECTION.
HELP US DO THAT.
YOU CAN GET YOUR ENTIRE FAMILY
TO DONATE TO ME THROUGH
LeeForSenate.com.
I WOULD INVITE YOUR VIEWERS TO
DO THE SAME.
IT'S A RACE GETTING CLOSER AND
CLOSER.
EVAN McMULLIN CONTINUES TO
RAISE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FROM
PROGRESSIVE DONORS NATIONWIDE
HELL-BENT ON PLACING ME WITH
EVAN McMULLIN.
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK THE
VOTERS OF UTAH UNDERSTAND HOW
FERVENTLY EVAN McMULLIN'S
DONORS HATE THE VALUES OF THE
STATE OF UTAH?
FOR REAL.
NOT ABOUT TAX RAISES.
DO YOU THINK YOUR VOTERS GET
BACK?
>> I DON'T.
THE LOCAL MEDIA IN UTAH IS
COMPLICIT.
THEY WANT EVAN McMULLIN TO WIN
FOR THAT REASON.
THEY ARE REFUSING TO ASK POLICY
QUESTIONS.
THEY ALLOW HIM TO ENGAGE IN
AD HOMINEM ATTACKS ON ME
NOTWITHSTANDING THAT HE CLAIMS
TO BE CAMPAIGNING ON THIS
PLATFORM OF CIVILITY WHICH IS
LAUGHABLE.
THEY NEVER MAKE HIM ANSWER ANY
ACTUAL POLICY QUESTIONS.
I THINK A LOT OF UTAH ONES ARE
BEATING -- ARE BEING DUPED AND
FOOLED.
THE TACIT ASSISTANCE OF MY
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUE FROM UTAH.
ALL 48 OF MY OTHER REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES ARE ON BOARD WITH ME,
HAVE SUPPORTED ME IN MY CAMPAIGN
AND OF INTEREST ME.
IT'S NOT TOO LATE, MITT.
YOU CAN JOIN THE PARTY.
I WELCOME YOU TO DO THOUGH
BECAUSE OTHERWISE YOU'LL BE
STUCK WITH TWO MORE YEARS OF
CHUCK SCHUMER BEING THE LEADER
AND TWO MORE YEARS OF JOE BIDEN
HAVING UNFETTERED RULE OVER THE
UNITED STATES SENATE.
WITHOUT ANY REPUBLICAN BACKSTOP.
>> Tucker: THIS IS A GUY WHO
MARCHED WITH BLACK LIVES MATTER
WHICH HATES NUCLEAR FAMILY AND
ENDORSE RIOTS.
LIKE, I THINK HE'S GONE INSANE.
MY VIEW, NOT YOURS.
SENATOR MIKE L